discutez réseauter et échanger des
cartes de visite dans une ambiance
décontractée
c'est l'esprit des linkedin locale un
concept né dans les pays anglophones
pour faciliter les rencontres et
développer les opportunités
professionnelles permettre à leurs
communautés de se rencontrer en offline
ce qu'on se rend compte que c'est des
réseaux qui sont très basses at on a
parfois connecter à des centaines voire
des milliers de personnes et c'est des
connexions qu'on n'exploite pas donc le
but c'est justement de permettre
d'activer ce réseau une dizaine de
villes en france adhère déjà au
mouvement paris nice lyon et maintenant
versailles le premier linkedin locales
dont la ville a été organisée mardi 27
mars à l'hôtel le louis plus de 50
personnes habitant ou exerçant dans la
cité royale et ses alentours ont
participé à la soirée
je me bats souvent contre versailles
cette belle endormie or on est une ville
dynamique avec une population souvent
active des profils professionnels
totalement différent et je pensais que
linky qui pouvaient un liant entre les
différentes personnes et c'était
vraiment l'occasion d'être ensemble au
delà du simple profil linkedin chefs
d'entreprise drh communicants ou encore
auto entrepreneurs les profils présents
à ce premier linkedin local versaillais
étaient variés c'est toujours
intéressant de pouvoir rencontrer
d'autres entrepreneurs et donc d'élargir
notre notre réseau c'est étonnant les
profils
complètement différents mais qui peuvent
apporter après
pourquoi pas
du business des nouvelles opportunités
on se retrouve beaucoup vu beaucoup de
versailles et et c'est très agréable
on se connaît parfois de vue et c'est
agréable pour échanger un petit peu un
nouveau linkedin local est d'ores et
déjà programmée à versailles le mardi 26
juin juste après le match de coupe du
monde de football france danemark